now a lot of you may know that i am a
long time zowie die hard who just
refuses to use any other mouse others in
the office think i'm crazy so they
tossed me a g pro super light in the
hopes that i would see the light or
whatever for starters it's wireless
which
is fine i guess the switches are nice
the side buttons slap and the scroll
wheel is way better than the mushy
useless piles of garbage on both the
za11 and za11b as for the shape it is
very original insofar as it isn't a
zowie copycat unobtrusive and can
certainly be said to suit any grip style
imaginable
as long as you're a toddler
unfortunately since i'm 6'5 and have 20
centimeter hands to boot
i quite simply cannot use this mouse
should logitech ever opt to make a
slightly larger gpro i would certainly
give it a second look but until that day
comes if it ever comes
boomer most it is